[Musique]
voici les quatre soeurs couture de
serrer mes de tenghory
les quatre filles se prépare à assurer
la relève de leurs parents qui élèvent
des porcs les transports et les vendent
directement à leur clientèle audrée la
cadette travail avec les animaux
surtout dans la pouponnière avec les
tout petits cochons et leur mère
je vais vérifier si tout le monde a bien
mangé 6
chaque fruit il n'y a pas de blessés ou
à quoi que ce soit mais aussi je dois
vérifier les retours à chaleur ou les
chats là pour aider à 6 nations c'est un
élevage de 188 ce matin dans la
maternité
il y en a sept qui donne naissance si
quelqu un triangle entre les joies les
aider
strauss & ball cvo à bord audrée fait
équipe avec l'hymne sa mère qui lui a
appris à s'occuper des animaux depuis
toujours c'est la manière habituelle de
transmettre le métier mais audrey a
voulu aller plus loin en étudiant la
gestion d'une entreprise agricole à
l'institut de technologie
agroalimentaire
au début je voulais être vétérinaire
c'est juste travailler avec les animaux
mais finalement après réflexion je me
suis dit quelle agriculture piet ja est
entourée d'animaux que des animaux qu'on
adore etc se sait ce que je veux dans le
fond
[Musique]
mais l'environnement de travail d'audrey
va bientôt changer dans nos projets
futurs il va falloir est née une
nouvelle base c'est cela qu'on est hard
déconstruit autre ton les filles
intègrent les méthodes de travail établi
par leurs parents comme la
transformation qui est d'abord la sphère
de cynthia ici on se rend dans le
département de la salaison donc six
îlots qu'on fait tout les 3 du salut qui
vont être ensuite fumée mouvement
mariage est aussi impliquée dans la
préparation des produits du porc
nina pologne qui viennent de sortir
ici
sinon
[Musique]
pour cynthia et marie-eve aussi
l'instruction a été un enjeu important
dans leur cas elles ont opté pour la
transformation des aliments
marianne a choisi l'université laval
après un petit détour au départ moi j'ai
fait une technique en soins infirmiers
parce que je me disais ça s'peut pas que
nos parents et transmis toute cette même
passion le pour finir en bout de ligne
que je suis ici et dans l'entreprise
familiale pour soutient ne pas court
vers l'agriculture a été plus direct
ça fait une grosse réflexion en fait ça
y allait de soi
écoutez j'ai fini second âge respaud
poser de questions let's go ans en
réalité à 5,5 dans une ferme diversifié
ça prend quelques aux finances il y en a
justement une qui a un baccalauréat en
agroéconomie caroline fait une
intégration graduelle dans l'équipe cage
y compris que like you sombre affaire
tong et dix entrepreneurs on est des
chefs d'entreprise les temps changent
tellement varié dans cette journée c'est
vraiment l'objet ou déclic lui
la ferme telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
et que les quatre soeurs s'apprête à
reprendre a été modifié par les parents
en 2004 nom à l'époque qu'un qu'on a
construit la jambonnière c'était pour
donc le pardonne être élevage transforme
en charcuterie pour distribuer dansant
du québec
j'étais la banque directe avant la
tendance aujourd'hui les filles
poursuivent avec ce modèle d'entreprise
parce qu'elle croit profondément à la
vente directe des produits de leur
élevage leurs projets d'expansion est
considérable elles veulent doubler le
nombre de porcs en élevage et transformé
beaucoup plus de bêtes que les 40%
actuelle donc 100 % de la production et
m'a tellement aura aussi qu'on a créé un
laboratoire pour pourfendre l'analyse de
nos ennemis et la relève compte bien en
profiter pour rajeunir les installations
c'est comment on s'en vient pas une
pleine capacité que fait que ce serait
vraiment que l'économie dans les usines
soit plus adapté à la nouvelle réalité
qu'on aujourd'hui c'est pour vraiment
s'adapte à notre croissance puisque
pouvoir me temps si on veut encore plus
croître mais qu'on soit bien l'équipe
riif puis bien adapté dans l'usiné en
productivité du projet de construction
les travaux à la porcherie doivent
débuter au printemps
trois parcs l'enfant
l'informatique geste alpi mecajet face à
face qui ont le projet de nouvelle
porcherie plus grande est conforme aux
dernières normes du bien-être animal est
emballant tant pour les enfants que les
parents en attendant d'être actionnaire
le point de vue des filles content quand
même
ils ont toujours travaillé aussi avec
nous aurons dès leur jeune âge ne
s'était pas un phare dont les soeurs
sont tonnes sur un point elles doivent
rajeunir certaines méthodes de travail
de l'autre génération non par un peu
plus la vis aux colts été fait sur
papier
et puis plus à bonne franquette
donc nous on apporte entamée plus cette
technologie qu'on assène informatisé
noms cités en premier un meilleur
contrôle pied de notre procédé en fait
[Musique]
formés aux sciences et technologies des
aliments mariage voit une foule de
possibilités pour améliorer la chaîne de
transformation tout qu'est-ce qui niveau
procédé niveau qualité je trouve qu'il
ya plein de choses à développer puis à
venir jouer son efficacité les façons de
faire que je trouve que c'est vraiment
stimulant
elles connaissent les grands défis qui
les attendent comme maintenir un emploi
une vingtaine de personnes ou satisfaire
et fidéliser leur clientèle
la majorité de mes amis sont aussi dans
le domaine agricole fac c'est le fun
parce qu'on peut échanger avec eux et de
nos problématiques de nos projets aussi
à venir donc on leur demande conseil
puis nous on leur donne des conseils
puis on partage nos expériences et des
villes
1 puis on s'encourage tout le monde dans
ce domaine le et comme fier d'eux et moi
je nourris le monde moi je contribue à
se nourrir le monde
je suis fier de ce que je produis puis
je suis fier de voir que les gens
apprécient mon produite
j'ai les coutures la passion s'est
transmise et l'éducation parentale a
porté ses fruits
si tu as les marques ont fait des
anecdotes
moi je leur disais parce qu'à
l'adolescence le salaire tentait pas
toujours le dernir travail et donc je
leur disais toujours à l' aider votre
père et va être content puis aujourd'hui
ils vont s'en vont pas travailler
ils vont céder entre autres dans le fond
mon modèle c'est ma mère j'ai travaillé
avec et depuis que j'ai 5 est un peu le
est depuis vraiment tout petit je pense
ma passion vient vraiment que de l qu
est ce qu elle m as me est ici pour être
maître le c'est la plus belle chose de
travail est axé son camp je me considère
chanceuse de pouvoir prendre la relève
d'améliorer encore plus l'entreprise l'a
apporté un autre sommet et puis
de valoriser la production production
porcine
je pense que chacun nous on voudrait
passer cela on suit la dda seul mais
ensemble on est vraiment appris puis on
a chacun nos forces
et puis on va jouer avec ce pour l
avenir d en confiance
[Rires]
[Musique]